[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de ce
qui m'a consacré à l'emploi et notamment
à cet événement qui aura lieu les 19 et
20 avril prochain le ski hit et je suis
en compagnie de Nicolas David bonjour
bonjour Patrice alors vous êtes le maire
de La Verrière évidemment et puis vous
êtes devis président de 50 ans en
Yvelines chargée de l'emploi de la
formation de l'apprentissage
alors on va parler évidemment de cet
événement vous allez nous dire pourquoi
vous voulez organiser mais d'abord
peut-être on pourrait faire un point sur
la situation de l'emploi sur le
territoire bah écoutez l'emploi
redémarre on a un niveau d'emploi qui
retrouve celui d'avant crise mais on a
encore des secteurs en forte tension le
BTP le numérique la santé avec le
Service à la Personne la mobilité on
cherche des conducteurs on cherche des
chauffeurs de train de bus et puis la
restauration et la sécurité d'autant
plus avec les JO qui arrivent en 2024 ça
nous aura pas échappé et là on a un
besoin criant de main d'oeuvre deux
talents dans ces secteurs particuliers
donc c'est en résumé il y a des offres
d'emploi ah bah il y en a on a
d'ailleurs le site ski emploi.fr qui
regorge toutes ces offres du territoire
pour essayer de correspondre à la
volonté des entreprises
vous nous direz tout à l'heure parce
qu'il y aura deux jours des pourquoi
vous avez dit l'emploi et puis
l'innovation mais peut-être on va
demander à Jean-Luc Béraud que vous
connaissez bien ne nous présenter cet
événement qu'est-ce que c'est que ce qui
pit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les 19 et 20 avril au Vélodrome national
nous organisons une grande opération que
nous avons appelée ski heat it pour
innovation et talent et donc avec une
première journée dédiée ou recrutement
des talents donc avec un niveau que nous
avons placé à bac +2 et plus et puis une
deuxième journée qui sera elle plus
dédiée à l'innovation mais également au
business pour permettre aux entreprises
grandes entreprises et PME et TPE
startup également de pouvoir trouver
tous les outils tous les dispositifs
toutes les mises en relation et pour
permettre à tous ce public
d'entrepreneurs de développer leur
activité dans les meilleures conditions
sur notre territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
les entreprises notamment les
entreprises de 50 ans en Yvelines sont
en pénurie d'union de pénurie en terme
de d'ingénieurs notamment mais pas que
donc c'est vraiment ce que nous ayons de
développer permettre à toutes ces
entreprises de trouver ici localement
les talents dont elles ont besoin et
pour lesquels ils ont aujourd'hui
beaucoup de difficultés à recruter
[Musique]
nous aurons des stands qui seront mis à
disposition de nos entreprises et puis
un grand espace dédié au rendez-vous on
prend un puits sur une plateforme cette
plateforme permettra à chacun de
s'inscrire tant entreprise que personne
ne recherche d'emploi ou alors pour des
rendez-vous business chacun validera les
rendez-vous qui lui sont proposés tous
les rendez-vous plus se tiendront sont
qualifiés voulus de part et d'autre pour
optimiser le temps de chacun durant une
vingtaine de minutes et faire en sorte
que ces rendez-vous aboutissent ou sur
du recrutement ou sur du business
[Musique]
il y aura certains nombre d'animations
qui permettront de promouvoir les Jeux
Olympiques à Saint-Quentin Yvelines
autour de tout ce qui va se passer ici
en termes de d'activités sportives
également en termes d'aménagement
d'impact pour les entreprises d'une
manière générale
[Musique]
alors Nicolas David on vient de le voir
pendant ces deux journées il y aura une
journée consacrée à l'emploi au
recrutement et puis une journée
consacrée aux entreprises et à
l'innovation pourquoi avoir voulu
regrouper ces deux événements dans ces
deux journées on a eu le modèle du Big
tour avec la BPI vous vous en souvenez
qui a très bien marché on a une ministre
de l'économie qui avait inauguré cet
événement et donc comme les entreprises
vous savez que l'agglomération n'est
aussi victime des hausses du coup
l’énergie on doit faire des économies
d'échelle et donc regrouper ces deux
événements le ski business D et en piste
pour l'emploi a du sens et c'est pour ça
qu'on l'a fait alors on parle beaucoup
des tensions sur le marché de l'emploi
quels sont les mesures que prend 50 ans
justement pour régler cette question des
tensions sur le marché de l'emploi alors
il y a beaucoup de mesures on a fait la
tasse force RH les DRH des entreprises
du territoire pour que l'agglomération
soit leur écoute et puisse adapter ces
formations mieux répondre à leurs
attentes on a également labellisé des
écoles notamment sur le numérique pour
répondre aux besoins des entreprises sur
le domaine de la cybersécurité en
l'occurrence et puis on essaye de réagir
différemment avec des nouvelles actions
là les talents de miser sur les soft
skills pas uniquement les diplômes mais
la magie
des candidats on a fait notamment le
street recruting où on a eu sur deux
jours près de 3000 contacts
différenciés et d'évaluer de manière
plus originale la personnalité des
candidats alors ce stricting c'était au
mois d'octobre dernier il y aura
peut-être un prochain au mois de juin je
vous propose de de retrouver un sujet
justement qui ne vous explique ce que
c'est ce Street recrute
[Musique]
bonjour Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
recrutent si vous êtes intéressé on est
plusieurs sociétés aujourd'hui
regroupées ici de 50 ans en Yvelines
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le marché du travail est
complètement inversé il y a quelques
années les candidats venaient aux
entreprises des entreprises
sélectionnées les candidats à ce jour
c'est aux entreprises de données envies
au candidats de nous rejoindre il est
important d'être connu de faire
connaître sur notre bassin de 50 ans en
Yvelines l'existence d'une richesse
d'entreprises dans différents domaines
d'activités pour avoir un effet direct
en terme de recrutement mais aussi un
effet indirect puisque les usagers de la
gare de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines où
nous avons effectué le street recruting
ont pu parler ainsi à leurs proches à
leurs amis à la relation professionnelle
des besoins de recrutement de Thalès sur
le bassin des longs
[Musique]
c'est important de recruter au niveau
local puisque les transports en commun
ou les longs trajets découragent les
candidats et c'est un risque de perte de
talent parce qu'ils sont fatigués tout
simplement d'avoir à subir ces
contraintes
[Musique]
pour batiweb ça reste extrêmement
compliqué de recruter en ligne on a
beaucoup moins de visibilité qu'une
grosse structure donc ça reste une très
belle opportunité notamment pour une PME
de présenter l'entreprise pour avoir une
visibilité en locale le marché du
recrutement est en tension donc il faut
essayer toutes les initiatives même les
plus innovantes le contact avec le les
candidats en direct sur le terrain
permet d'humaniser notre approche de
recrutement d'authentifier nos
recruteurs et donner envie de poursuivre
la rencontre
[Musique]
donc si ça peut vous intéresser pour
vous ou pour une personne de votre
entourage n'hésitez pas à postuler ça
marche ça se passe sur 50 ans Yvelines
ok bon courage au revoir monsieur
[Musique]
Nicolas Barville vous souvenez quelques
souvenirs vous gardez de cette opération
de streeting ben écoutez un excellent
souvenir c'est vrai qu'en termes
d'emploi il y a une tendance de fond qui
est d'aller vers de pas attendre que les
gens viennent dans les structures mais
que les structures les entreprises avec
sur le terrain au contact des vrais gens
dans la vraie vie pour les évaluer de
manière différente et donc c'est un très
beau moment où on mise également sur le
sport parfois pour recruter des
candidats en lien aussi avec les Jeux
Olympiques pour recruter aussi
personnalité des compétences hors
diplôme comme je le disais et donc cette
tendance là on la retrouve aussi dans
toutes les structures d'accompagnement
vers l'emploi la Mission Locale ce qui
est 16-25 qui va aussi de plus en plus
sur le terrain les associations
donc c'est une tendance de fond et une
tendance rien de vous la rencontre au
fond l'autre fois on a en très grande
ouvriers les CV etc c'est un peu anodine
aujourd'hui la rencontre oui c'était
essentielle parce que comme on le dit
elle sait découvrir aussi des
personnalités au-delà des diplômes ou
au-delà des parcours exactement c'est
exactement ça alors on parlait de ce qui
cube
qui est évidemment accueille beaucoup de
start-up mais qui a aussi un rôle en
matière d'emploi ben oui on est comme le
dit le président Jean-Michel fourgouse
parmi les huit zones les plus innovantes
du monde 50 ans en Yvelines et donc il
faut qu'on mise sur l'innovation et donc
on a créé il y a quelques années ce ski
cube qui est donc cette incubateur à
startup pour les faire croître et on a
effectivement depuis maintenant son
ouverture une dizaine de startups qui
chaque année sont dans les locaux qui
permet ensuite d'avoir des entreprises
ce qui est source d'emploi et puis dans
ce stucu on a aussi une vocation plus
sociale de mise en contact
de public plus éloignés de l'emploi avec
start-up on avait vous savez les
déterminés l'association donc de
moussakamura avec lesquels on avait
contractualisé pour justement aussi
permettre à des gens des quartiers de
créer une entreprise et
j'ajoute la question des Invisibles on a
vous savez ces publics qui sont sortis
des écrans radars qui sont dans nos
quartiers et donc on forme aussi voilà
des endroits exactement des ambassadeurs
de ces politiques de l'emploi qui sont
des médiateurs des trucs des personnes
issues des structures communales pour
aller chercher ces fameuses invisibles
et les emmener au ski cube ou dans nos
structures d'accompagnement à l'emploi
puisqu'on parle de startup est-ce que
vous connaissez une startup qui est à
trappe je crois qu'il s'appelle RDI
manager affirmatif très belle startup
très belle startup je vous propose de
voir le portrait de son créateur qui
s'appelle Kevin klefendji
[Musique]
nous avons développé ce journal
collaboratif de projet parce qu'on s'est
rendu compte que beaucoup de situations
de gestion de projet avait besoin de
capitaliser l'information technique
pertinente nous sommes installés à 50
ans en Yvelines d'une part parce que je
connaissais déjà le territoire j'ai fait
ma thèse au Technocentre et d'autres pas
parce qu'on nous recherchons un
écosystème d'innovation et des locaux
accessibles économiquement et la
pépinière d'entreprise de trappe que
chez toutes les cases
c'est parce que j'ai été ingénieur de
recherche dans des grands centres de
recherche j'ai observé comment on y
travaillait et puis j'ai compris quels
étaient les bonnes pratiques et qu'elle
était aussi les fins à un développement
fluide et rapide en ce moment on vit une
époque où l'innovation drive toute
l'activité alors il faut aller vite
parce que le marché a besoin de ça et ne
pas se faire doubler et c'est là où on
s'est dit on va développer un outil
simple efficace pour accompagner les
entreprises les petites comme les
grandes pour faire simple RD managers ça
permet de capitaliser l'information
technique pertinente du projet et puis
de la partager avec les parties
prenantes
[Musique]
nous avons rejoint récemment la tasse
force RH de 50 ans en Yvelines tout
simplement parce qu'en tant que jeune
entreprises n'avons pas beaucoup
d'expérience en recrutement et nous nous
rendons compte que c'est loin d'être
simple et au sein de la casse RH il y a
des grandes entreprises moyennes mais
qui ont plus d'expérience en termes de
recrutement et ça nous permet de changer
des bonnes pratiques et on Acquier aussi
de leur expérience qui nous permet
d'être plus efficace en termes de
recrutement
[Musique]
côté recrutement nous avons vraiment
utilisé les actifs du territoire la
plateforme Sky emploi et les événements
que le Sky cube organise pour l'emploi
des collaborateurs et nous avons pu
recruter plusieurs de nos collaborateurs
via ces différents leviers
[Musique]
Nicolas David pour conclure ce magazine
consacré à l'emploi qu'est-ce qu'on peut
souhaiter dans les mois qui viennent
dans ce domaine justement de l'emploi et
puis déjà une belle réussite pour cet
événement de ski tu auras plusieurs
milliers de rendez-vous donc il faut que
ça soit le plus fructueux possible pour
les candidats et pour les entreprises et
puis je souhaite une situation plus
apaisée c'est vrai qu'on a une hausse
assez dramatique du coup des énergies
qui provoquent une inflation terrible
même dans le secteur de la de la
distribution et donc j'espère que l'État
sera au rendez-vous à l'écoute des
acteurs de terrain moi technocratique
c'est ce que fait pour la France et pour
la situation de l'emploi merci beaucoup
Nicolas Maville on rappelle les dates de
cette événement skit c'est donc les 19
et 20 avril prochain et c'est au
Vélodrome de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
merci beaucoup merci Patrice
[Musique]